well you know what you're going to get
from wade miley he's going to try to
establish that fastball that cutter on
the inside part of the plate open up the
outside part of the plate with the
breaking ball
schwindel rips that one into left field
that'll touch down roll all the way to
the fence
frank headed for second throw comes in
and he's got a double
frank schwendell stays hot
swing and miss down goes wisdom first
strikeout for milo justin steele on the
mount making his second major league
start four-seam fastball slider sinker
curveball an occasional change-up but a
lot of four-seam fastballs likes to
pitch that up and into the righties good
sinker good slider
that one in there struck him out
and steel does a really good job
pitching out of the jig
big chop toward the middle gloved by
alcantara sets the feet makes a good
throw to get him excellent play by
sergio alcantara showing both good range
and a good arm man at first barnhart at
the plate barnhart is hit safely in five
of six and he rips that one into right
field that's gonna get down face it
skips over the fence and that's gonna
hold back the lead man tyler naquin
he'll have to freeze it third barnhart
bangs a double
that is what we call a hanging breaking
ball
you hang it we bang it wade miley
has seven hits this year two
against the cubs
that one bunted and they're coming home
tagged out well done
suicide squeeze
and steal with the glove able to shovel
to the plate and they cut down the
runner naquin at the dish
nick castiano sees a shift free
infielders third base side of second
broken back to first base backhand
awkward sliding stop schwendell stabbing
try for steel is off
and castialos legs out the broken back
in field here
can joey votto do more damage with the
man on
up the middle kicks off the bag
castillanos rips through second third
base is unoccupied
vargas on the charge lobs it in
bottle rips a single up the middle first
and third
1999 hits
for joseph daniel otto steele is ready
and deals
not a swing and a miss he went upstairs
got the strikeout farmer is gone
steel fires
got him looking struck him out
and suarez doesn't like the call from
chris siegel a good job of trino staying
with that pitch
framing it presenting it to the umpire
exactly where it was on the outside
corner
lifted the shallow left charging in as
wisdom patrick the grab
and again justin steele pitches around a
pair of singles
man at first two down still no score
bottom of the fourth
india blast off to left
by by baseball and upward decker from
jonathan india
well here's the fastball
didn't get inside where he's been living
cannot live over the heart of the plate
especially to a hot jonathan india
my goodness
aquino who is grounded out to short fly
to left
aquino
booms it
twice a red has touched the top deck and
left
a two out two run tater from aristina's
aquino
talked about guys stepping up
and jesse
winker's absence
aquino getting more run
and that's what the punisher can do
joey bottom one hit shy of 2
000.
payoff
2 000 hits
for joey bottle
not only the fans in the seats but
the reds teammates in the dugout
all a standing ovation for joey votto
and he hits
2 000 a dead set bullet into center
field another all-time moment for an
all-time player the face of the
franchise joseph daniel motto
[Applause]
farmer rips that one deep left
off the wall castellanos around third
stop sign for bottom throw to the plate
no shot castellamos crosses standing rvi
double kyle farmer it's five nothing
and he walks aquino to push in a run
votto jogs home it's six nothing reds
to the unoccupied shortstop position
station to station advance farmer scores
suarez held up
seven
zip
nobody out the first six reds have
reached
booms one to ride hayward makes the
catch
tag at third by suarez he sprints home
zach fly rbi
hey nothing reds
jonathan india
fair ball
aquino scores naquin given the wave
barrero green light naked crosses
barrero slides in safely
three run double jonathan india a triple
shy of the cycle
do up for a second time this inning
bottle to the left
wisdom can't get there india scores
three hits a walk and an rbi on vato's
magic night
and the reds have matched their most
explosive ending of the season eight are
in it's 12 to nothing bases are still
loaded with two out and the batter will
be robinson torinos
that one lied out towards left center
that'll fall for a hit ortega is in
duffy on his heels he comes in to score
and robinson chirinos
able to get the cubs on the board it's
12-2
hayward rips that one out towards right
center that's gonna roll all the way to
the fence
into score is schwendel charinos will
stop at third hayward
with a hard hit two
and it's 12-3
two and two to half with two outs
that's line that's a fair ball that's
heading towards the corner and it'll
score two
torinos and hayward half into second
tenth hit of the night for the cubs ian
hack with a two run double
and the cubs have scored five times here
in the eighth
tucker barnhart has had a strong night
[Applause]
barnhart big blast deep right center
[Applause]
there's that breaking ball again
just stays up
the reds are rolling
[Applause]
akiyama
makes the catch and the reds route the
cubs
in the home stand opener of 14-5
bashing at great american ballpark
you